hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in his Poetics Aristotle is
going to provide us with some
definitions that he actually quite
literally calls definitions this is a
bit of a side note but sometimes when
people are reading through Aristotle's
Works they will import this term
definition into their understanding or
the translation of what Aristotle's
saying when he doesn't actually use the
term horros which means definition or
the verbal forms of this in this section
he actually tells us that he's giving us
a definition a horrors of the nature or
the substance the usia of tragedy itself
as a type of mimesis and then when he
goes through the different parts or
components however we want to translate
merre he will actually say that now that
we believe Define them dioris Menon the
two-tone right now we're going to talk
about these other matters so he he
really is intending to Define things
both in terms of tragedy itself and in
terms of its parts so what is the
definition of the essence of tragedy it
tells us four main things and there's
some other things that we could add to
this later on but what is explicitly
saying here is that it's a lamesis an
imitation right so it's a type of
mimesis there are many different sorts
um a mimesis of
action so it's not just mimesis of any
old thing but Praxis and Praxis means
action it's actually going to be actions
plural as we're going to see and also
matters pragmaton which is connected
with with Praxis so
mimesis of action that is now we can
translate this term as elevated or
another term would be decent or serious
right a term that we often see used as
equivalent to you know virtuous or
serious or on the way to Virtue in other
places when it's applied to a person
when we're talking about an action the
action itself is something that is
important also then complete so brought
to its fruition would be a good way of
translating teles right tele is the goal
or the end we're going to see him
discussing that a bit in this section
and of magnitude and you might say well
how is elevated and of magnitude how are
these different from each other in the
Greek of magnitude
megathos exuses right so having a
certain
Grandeur we might say so you know
elevated would or c curious would apply
to the action itself and then it's
dealing with important things right so
that's one part
that's telling us what it's about the
objects
in language embellished by distinct
forms in its sections Aristotle will
actually provide us with a little gloss
on this he says I used embellished
for language with rhythm and Melody and
distinct forms for the fact that some
parts are conveyed through metrical
speech alone others through songs so in
tragedy there would be portions of it
that would actually be sung and then
there are portions of it that are just
just spoken it's all through
the the forms of making it interesting
making it pretty and we're going to see
this discussed in terms of Lexus in just
a bit
mode how this is actually done the hosts
in Greek the way in which things are
conveyed enactment
right this is the word that drama is
actually going to come from According to
Aristotle
um things that are being done things
that are shown as being done and not
through narrative or announcing as we
would see for example in epic poetry you
know when Homer is telling us about you
know the conflict in in book one of The
Iliad between Agamemnon and achilles he
allows each of them to speak but he also
narrates what's going on right Achilles
is about to draw his sword and strike
Agamemnon down where he stands because
he's inflamed with anger but he doesn't
do it
well that's narrated on stage it would
actually be enacted in in some way
and then here's a particularly
interesting and distinctive feature of
Aristotle's account of tragedy catharsis
which means something like purification
or cleaning so through to particular
emotions pity Laos and fear Phobos
producing catharsis in in the audience
members but perhaps also in the actors
right of those emotions so this is what
Aristotle takes as being of the essence
of tragedy these are the things that are
really distinctive does this cover
everything that tragedy does or is no
there's other matters as well but these
are at the very core of what Aristotle
takes tragedy to be
now he also then immediately after
telling us that is going to start
talking about the aspects or elements or
parts quite literally of tragedy and
he's going to do this in several
different ways first he talks about
actors rendering them a mesis so there's
the arrangement of spectacle and that's
actually the thing he considers to be
the least important the op system we'll
get to that in a moment he goes on and
says to this we can add lyric poetry and
diction why these are the media in which
they render the mimesis the actors
actually do this and then he tells us
what addiction is and lyric poetry is
we're going to get to those in a moment
then he says since tragedy is mimesis of
an action and the action is conducted by
agents or people who should have certain
qualities in both character and thought
because it's those factors that allow us
to ascribe qualities to their actions
the the plot is the uh mimesis of the
action so we've got the other things
together and he says tragedy must have
six components which give it the tragedy
its quality it's what it's like what are
these plot character diction thought
spectacle and lyric poetry and then he
tells us the media the the you know what
the PO what the uh mimesis is in are two
the mode is one that's the spectacle and
it's objects three there are no others
this is what tragedy is really about in
terms of its components so now we've got
like components of tragedy the the
working parts and we've got the
definition of what tragedy is what it
does this tells us a lot
particularly when we look at
the other things that he tells us
he's defining these these parts and he
actually sets them out in an order of
importance plot
muthos
is the absolutely most important part of
tragedy According to Aristotle
he actually goes so far as to say you
could have a tragedy that has plot but
doesn't really have
character meaning that the writer
doesn't effectively convey character of
the characters right they're kind of
just generic blah blah blah boring sorts
but it could have a plot right that's
not a good tragedy of course and we
don't have any examples of that because
the Greeks you know we only have the
best examples presumably second and
importance character a thing now this is
not just having a cool character it
means the type of person morally
speaking who this character is that's
important for tragedy then we have
thought deanoia third in importance
right conveying the ideas of the
characters within the scope of the story
itself fourth in importance diction
Lexus a term that Aristotle uses both in
this and in the rhetoric in book three
where he devotes considerable discussion
to it so if you want to know more about
Lexus that may be a place for you to go
but and then we have Fifth and
importance lyric poetry
this is actually song right so the parts
of the the tragedy where actors are
singing things out and then we have
spectacle opsis which includes like you
know stage construction and the costume
rooms and the masks and all of that sort
of stuff we might actually include
choreography in there as well although
there could be a reason why we would
leave it out and and perhaps think of
that as being part of how character or
plot is conveyed so let's look at each
of these six parts in turn so plot
he's going to use two really important
closely connected words to convey what's
going on here so it's the construction
the synthesis of the matters the
pragmatone pragmaton are the things that
are being you know thought about talked
about done uh it comes from the word for
Action prachane which we get Praxis the
action itself from and then the
fragments on the things that the action
is about or perhaps the consequences uh
he also talks about the structure the
sustasis of the matters using the same
word now you notice the sun ensus these
are words that in Greek mean together
thesis means placing something so things
are placed together and then the
sustasis things are also stuck together
uh there's there's there are a range
in some sort of
complex order and he's going to tell us
um that you know this is the most
important element of it the events and
plot are the goal of tragedy the goal
the Telos is the most important thing of
all the most important of these matters
is the structure event because tragedy
is mimacious not of persons it's not
just a character study but
of
action
praxos and life beyond now he's not
meaning life just in a big broad capital
L generic sense like tragedy is about
life you know theater is life
he means particular ways of living
the products of our you know
conditioning and choices and Our Fate
perhaps even in that so this is uh
incredibly important right
he's he's going to tell us that the
action that's being narrated actually
presented in the story uh you know the
narration thing is kind of interesting
because characters do narrate what's
going on don't they so that might be
something that we have to
bring into a little bit of bracketing so
plot absolutely important
what about character now
as I mentioned you said you could have a
tragedy without character but it's not a
very good tragedy right we actually want
compelling characters characters that
can move us that we can identify with
that we can take all sorts of emotional
stances towards including fear and pity
but perhaps also anger or Joy or sadness
or all of the other emotions what is it
so he says it's in virtue of character
that people have certain qualities that
they're of certain types
right so character is telling us you
know the kind of person that somebody is
and that's really uh Central he also
says what is character it's in that that
in virtue of which we ascribe certain
qualities to the actors to the agents we
said this is a good person this is a bad
person what kind of good person are they
they're courageous they're cowardly
right they're uh wise they're foolish
they're just they're unjust notice that
we're using the language of Virtues and
vices in this
that's pretty important so he says that
um
you know we have to we have to develop a
scribe certain uh characters to people
and he's going to tell us that character
is what reveals what we translate is
moral choice racist your think about it
as you're sometimes you say moral
compass your values your commitments
your priorities all of that is there in
this notion of moral choice character is
the kind of person that a character in
the play is and he says what kinds of
things and a person chooses or rejects
right what it is that they are about we
say so character is very important then
we have thought the annoying
and it's interesting because we
typically think of well you know there's
what I think and then what I say so in a
tragedy the characters reveal what it is
that they think by saying it or
sometimes by what they do sometimes by
what other people say about them you're
this kind of person you're following
this sort of line of reasoning and they
may do that rightly or wrongly a great
example of this is crayon in Sophocles
Antigone where he's saying everybody's
run by money right that that's wrong
clearly Antigone isn't clearly the
century who just wants to get away after
giving the bad news isn't but this shows
you what Creon thinks and so Aristotle
tells us that it's how characters
demonstrate and he uses the term for
that to bring forth to show right
or declare what it is that they actually
think
he says that we can demonstrate that
something is or is not so so something
particular or we can declare a general
view about things you know we can say
people are all like this we can talk in
in universals
and when he talks about declaring their
view it's kind of an interesting term
they're gnome their judgment their
viewpoint on things and so all three of
these plot character thought are the
things that tragedy is about the objects
of tragedy and so a successful tragedy
has to do a lot of work integrating
these together
then we get to what we can call the
media how is it that
tragedy actually conveys things asthma
mesis and then we get diction Lexus
right he calls this the composition of
the speech right so how do you actually
say things how do the characters say
things
and this is what the playwright is
putting into the mouths of the
characters or the expression through the
various choices of words what kind of
language are you choosing and this ties
in with character and thought right so
somebody who's just a humble servant is
going to have kind of humble language
somebody who's a big proud Tyrant
overweening language if if you flip them
that's not quite the right diction or
Alexis
about lyric poetry Aristotle actually
tells us oh this is entirely clear I
don't actually need to tell you what
that is you all know what it is
and I think we do it's it's the things
that are song
um
within the the play now what's most
interesting about this is that in
talking about the ordering of importance
he's going to tell us that it's the
greatest embellishment mega stone toe
hey Deuce mattone now embellishment
um kind of an abstract term let's change
it instead to it's the greatest Maggie
Stone
um the greatest of the pleasure giving
aspects right we like to hear the
singing people still do love musicals
right and even sometimes if you're doing
a interesting show that doesn't usually
have musical numbers in it they'll
sometimes be an episode where every
everybody's singing people like that
sort of thing so Aristotle thinks that's
an important part of it and this might
actually tie in with the how you arouse
pity and and fear you know because music
plays a role in that and then finally
the last part spectacle or opsis this is
quite interesting because he's going to
tell us
that it is as he says emotionally potent
right and the word for that is
right so tsukagike is or sukhagecon is
something that amuses us arouses us
keeps our attention something that
literally drives our soul right it
pushes our soul in a certain way
um but
Aristotle thinks that this isn't really
that important it's it's not something
that the writer of the tragedy needs to
be super concerned with I mean they're
going to put the tragedy on stage
um but he says that it's actually a
techno-toton which means it's not really
part of the technique of writing tragedy
it's something that you do so you can
put it on the stage and he says that
it's not really Central or integral oike
to the Poetry it's sort of something
that we add on he says a tragedy the
power of it
um is independent of performance and
actors and the costumers art has more
scope than the poets for rendering
effects of spectacle so it's it's as if
um this is you know important in the
sense that you got to put tragedies on
stage but it's not the tragedy in the
poet who handles that they can leave
that to the Lesser people who handle
those details of appearance and we might
contest this right we could say oh no
this is actually quite important but
Aristotle thinks that it's of lesser
importance but it's still one part
of tragedy so we've got an arrangement
of of importance we've got the
interconnections between them and as
Aristotle tells us we have actually
defined all six of these as well as
tragedy as a whole so we've got some
pretty firm definitions Aristotle could
be wrong of course but at least we know
exactly what his Viewpoint is